le salon de l'agriculture joue trois
savent couvert quotidiennement en direct
et pour notre plus grand plaisir par
France 3 dont je salue le programmateur
qui déniche les invités les plus à même
de parler des sujets qui sont abordés
agriculture et nourriture ce
sera
pour parler agriculture salut Barbara en
toute transparence on va raconter ce qui
s'est passé tu étais prévu pour venir
hier avec nous au salon de l'agriculture
tu étais prête avec tes arguments
fourche avec ta fourche on a eu un
message du staff de la sécurité du salon
qui nous a dit attention certains
agriculteurs sont en train de préparer
un comité d'accueil particulier pour
Barbara Lefebvre ils sont contre tes
prises de position animalistes
pour moi
alors comment casser une ambiance
immédiatement demande au champion du
monde alors lui dit on a un point commun
elle est morte de rire elle pense on est
de la même ville tout ça et en fait non
c'est vrai que jeudi quand on en parlait
avec un linge j'en ai mis un peu j'en ai
remis un peu une couche sur la nsea donc
apparemment ça leur plaît pas trop c'est
dommage c'est dommage d'abord c'est
dommage pour les missions de venir
attaquer une émission je sais pas si
vous de faire ça en direct mais je t'ai
du fumier ou quoi c'est pas grave
faire de la perturbation
oui c'est pas de savoir faire la cuisine
pour moi
alors là
c'est immédiat l'ambiance se ferme assez
vite voici un sourire que Guy Savoie n'a
pas dû garder longtemps en apprenant la
nouvelle le guide Michelin lui retire
une étoile il ne lui en reste plus que
deux jusqu'à présent je n'avais connu
que des meilleurs moments dans ma
carrière ce soir je pense aux équipes et
je vais leur parler dès demain on a
perdu le match cette année mais on va le
regagner l'année prochaine immense
surprise pour Guy Savoie il avait été
élu meilleur chef au monde pour la
sixième fois consécutive en novembre
dernier d'autres grands chefs sont
sanctionnés comme le Toulousain Michel
Saran qui perd lui sa deuxième étoile
j'avoue que hier j'ai quand même eu
quelques larmes que j'ai eu des
témoignages des gens qui me soutiennent
il y a des gens qui m'aiment et bon
c'est pas Michelin qui va changer ça
c'est à peu près comme si vous avez un
film qui est décrié par la critique et
qui fait ça le plein qui a raison qui a
tort nouvelle preuve s'il en fallait une
de la baisse du pouvoir d'achat d'une
partie des Français le nombre de
personnes ayant fréquenté l'an dernier
les Banques Alimentaires étant hausse
près de 2 millions et demi de Français
sont désormais recours et parmi eux plus
d'un tiers sont de nouveau bénéficiaires
qui ne se rendaient pas dans ces
structures il y a encore six mois le
gouvernement lance un plan baptisé mieux
manger pour tous 60 millions d'euros
débloqués pour aider les quatre millions
de bénéficiaires de l'aide alimentaire
j'ai appris de ne plus manger de viande
rouge en tout cas très peu maintenant
j'en mange tous les 10 jours voilà une
fois tous les 10 jours je mange de la
viande rouge mais par contre je vous
avoue que quand je rentre en rouge tous
les 10 jours je me fais plaisir et c'est
une belle côte de boeuf senior mais
voilà mais en attendant pendant 9 jours
j'en ai pas mangé quoi
que vous veniez il y a des ballons des
Serpentards
un orchestre mais vraiment vous faites
pas savoir d'ailleurs les gens dans le
quartier va manger de la viande
ou alors que le fermer et après c'est le
balance comme ça ils sont tout comme
dans l'autre
ma vie mais on va y arriver il y a une
grosse technique
[Applaudissements]
Koh-Lanta ça c'est des petites filles
c'est pour ça qu'elles font la lessive
la plupart est aussi leur mère a fumé le
poisson
les garçons apprennent à lancer des
filets avec leur père pour qu'une fois
adulte il devienne pécheurs à leur tour
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
nouvelle vague de licenciement chez
Twitter environ 200 salariés ont été
virés ces derniers jours dont Esther
Crawford la tête pensante de la nouvelle
offre payante de Twitter en novembre
dernier peu après le rachat du groupe
par Elon Musk cette cadre avait partagé
une photo d'elle en train de dormir dans
son bureau pour tenir les délais
insuffisant pour Elon Musk qui sait donc
séparé de cet employé dévoué 176
milliards
Bill Gates qui a fait fortune dans les
portes de l'aéroport non mais 114
milliards il y a Jeff Bezos dans les
baisers
[Rires]
le traitement des déchets est inexistant
sous chaque cabane à perte de vue des
morceaux d'or dur
quand tu milliards d'euros c'est notre
chiffre du jour et c'est un record le
montant des recettes engrangées l'an
dernier par la France grâce au tourisme
international les étrangers reviennent
visiter notre pays qui attire d'abord
les Européens les Américains aussi les
touristes asiatiques restent moins
nombreux qu'avant la pandémie le site
français le plus visité reste de loin à
Disneyland Paris les gens jettent tous
leurs déchets dehors
[Applaudissements]
en réalité ça vient de tout Lagos il y a
un grand canal qui déverse tous les
déchets à Makoko
et Elon Musk donc voilà c'est ils ont
des milliards de dollars qu'est-ce que
ça veut dire des milliards de dollars
c'est un milliard
donc ils ont
187 fois mille millions si vous avez
compris
un milliards
[Musique]
un déballage un peu surréaliste dans une
ville où la majorité des habitants vit
avec moins de 2 dollars par jour que je
vienne ou pas ça ne change pas à ce que
je gagne dans la vie je vous jure que
c'est vrai c'est voilà c'est ça ne
change rien limite je vous jure que
c'est vrai je gagnerai plus d'argent si
je venais pas ah je ne savais pas si je
produisais seulement l'émission
je vous jure que c'est vrai